so on monday we talked to one of the
co-owners of a bar called
max public house it's in staten island
new york
he told us that his restaurant was now
an autonomous zone
and that he would defy the governor's
chronovirus lockdowns those lockdowns
didn't make any sense to him you could
walk a block away from mac's public
house and eat indoors
and he said that out loud that might
have been a mistake because last night
authorities
hauled the co-owner of max public house
a man called danny presti
away in handcuffs tonight right now a
large group of supporters has gathered
outside
that restaurant corner danny preston
joins us tonight with his attorney
lou joel amino uh
danny and lou thanks so much for coming
on first
tell us danny you were arrested because
your business partner
said publicly is my understanding that
he was defying the orders what happened
uh we had a little meeting inside
yesterday
i did have some guests in there um
sheriffs came in uh seemed like a whole
lot of them
we were really good with them really
cordial
and uh
after a while uh just wanted to take me
out
seemed a whole big ordeal
so so lou danny was arrested
in a city where people push human beings
in front of subway trains and get away
with it
why do you think your client was singled
out for all the criminals in new york
right now
for jail
tucker thanks for having us i have to
tell you my mother-in-law is battling
cancer and she's your absolute biggest
fan
but as far as my client goes they came
in
15 sheriffs came in yesterday
we were peaceful quiet respectful
and cordial the whole entire time i told
my clients to be that way
everybody acted that way and at the end
of the day
after giving out over fifty thousand
dollars in fines
and finding me and giving me four
summonses for just representing my
client
in a polite respectful manner they gave
us fifty thousand dollars in fines
throughout the
throughout the building and wind up
arresting danny and putting him in
handcuffs and charging him with
disorderly conduct
when he never raised the voice and he
was in his own building
that he is the leaseholder on him it's
shocking now this is i should tell our
audience
i'm not sure what we're looking at this
is happening live what is going on
around you right now who are the people
outside your bar and what are they
saying
tucker we have 1500 over 1500 staten
island
is protesting tonight there's probably a
thousand
left and we are peacefully protesting no
rioting
no looting we have about 25 sheriff's
deputies out in front of the place
that were kind of aggressive at times
but we have 1500 staten islanders in a
peaceful protest
protesting and supporting business
owners local business owners
and danny and keith and the actions they
took to stand up for themselves
and staten islanders and business owners
everywhere
so i i don't think we've seen a protest
like this so far
i expect we're going to see more in
coming days but you're saying
these are people protesting the governor
and the mayor's
corona lockdowns
governor uh tucker you've been on it
from the beginning they are protesting
the fact
that the governor and all his wisdom
split staten island in half
and and considered the south shore of
staten island
an orange zone and the north shore of
staten island a yellow zone
just a block in a way a block and a half
away
from max tavern literally a block and a
half you can go sit down have a burger
and a beer but at max's tavern you can't
do it and coincidentally
tucker the south shore of staten island
did not vote
for governor cuomo or mayor de blasio
the the
the the side of of the borough that's
that's shut down
under coronal law now is there a
scientific basis for this
that you know of
i don't know i talk i mean use some
common sense we'll all use some common
sense
and we're going to assume i'm not a
scientist i'm an attorney
that the covent virus doesn't stop
doesn't stop at the railroad tracks
where you can go
eat a block away i'm assuming the covert
virus doesn't stop there
but in in governor cuomo's wisdom i have
no idea what signs they've used
what are the police doing right now you
said there are sheriff's deputies on the
scene
yep the sheriff's on the scene they've
created a blockade in front
they won't let anybody in they said
they're not going to leave anytime
soon we do want to make clear though
that they are not the nypd these are the
new york city sheriffs
so nypd has worked with us
really good guys we support them fully
this is the new york city sheriff
department and they have created a
blockade and will not let anybody in the
place except for myself keith and luke
danny is is your bar open
now um
they won't even if we wanted to try to
get in there they have literally created
a blockade of about 25
sheriffs standing in front with barriers
so there's no way anybody can get in
right now there's a blockade at taco a
literal blockade
honestly i gotta ask you this question
on the way out
how many confirmed cases of transmission
the chronovirus
have come from max pub that you know of
zero there's absolutely zero tucker
and i i think there's zero a block and a
half away where you can eat also
yeah i just want to just want to
establish we're not dealing with typhoid
mary here
danny and lou i appreciate your coming
on tonight good luck
thank you tucker thanks for having us
and thanks for all the work you do we
really appreciate it thank you
so